more stunning incompetence from New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo more than 5,000
nursing home residents died in his state
after he ordered Kovac patients be
returned to assisted living facilities
and now he's admitting he wouldn't send
his own mother to nursing home during
the crisis what if I were advising a
friend I would say you have a vulnerable
person best to keep them at home and not
put them in a congregate facility keep
them in a situation where you have the
most control that is the blunt truth
that's what I would do with my mother so
so Dana
very telling in his interview he's
taking a hit in the polls right now and
I want to pop this up 48% of New Yorkers
right now when it comes to his handling
have an ADA negative view of him and the
way he's handled this nursing home work
the governor has been on all these press
conferences he got praise from both
sides will this destroy that narrative
right now well it had to come back down
to earth once the facts started to get
out there he is not used to being
questioned he was riding high for so
long and you know having fun with his
brother on CNN and then this story was
relentless and so this is where
journalism actually catches up and he
has is forced to answer it you know he
there was a story by Peter Hausen about
how they're counting the numbers of
nursing home deaths and maybe altering
them and there were there was days of
media coverage when it was suggested
that the woman down in Florida in charge
of the data had been manipulating them
and that she got fired and it that was
inappropriate that turned out to be fake
news and then you have this story and
it's not getting as much attention but I
think because people are so upset that
their loved ones that could have lived
an average of ten years longer we're
putting these positions now the last
thing I'll say is great for him then he
could have the resources to take care of
his own mother if he had to most people
don't have that capability and they have
to rely on a place in order to help them
help their loved ones
and it's hard enough to make that
decision that you have to put your
parent or your loved one into a nursing
home without him piling on and saying
well basically saying if you cared more
you would keep them home that's if
that's disgustingly unfair Marie you
know a lot of the pushback depth that
the mayor I'm sorry that the governor is
getting right now is that a lot of the
families want to sue they want to get
involved and they're not able to sue
because the mayor gave these hospital
executives immunity what are your
thoughts about that mm-hmm well Governor
Cuomo said that he made this decision
because he was following initial CDC
guidance going back to CDC guidance
again that I think 10 other states also
followed that turned out to be
tragically not good so he certainly does
bear responsibility I think governor's
should be able to trust the guidance
they're getting from the CDC and in this
case that that wasn't true I think with
litigation it's gonna be very messy on
this issue and many others related to
kovat I don't know how it's going to
play out but it's gonna be messy Jesse I
interview some folks and they'll be on
Hannity tonight that their mother died
as a result of this and they didn't
isolate these patients you know the one
lady told me you know I brought my mom
in with a leg injury and she left in a
body bag that was a real quote or your
thoughts on that mmm
yeah they were sending body bags to
these nursing homes along with patients
like a two-for-one deal Marie's wrong
about the guidelines the guidelines
didn't say stuff sick people in the
nursing homes it was a lot more than
that and if those were the guidelines
why didn't de santis do it he did
something totally different and that was
brilliant and he saved countless lives
now when I do something wrong I blame
everybody but myself you know I blame
Greg he set me up I'll say other
producers screwed up I'll try to delete
an email
it's exactly what Cuomo did remember
what he did first he played dumb Oh what
directive and then he said oh you know
what in the dark he tried to like delete
it and then he said oh well Trump told
me to do it and now he said no it's the
nursing homes fault so he got caught
red-handed and now he's scrambling and
everybody could see he made a bonehead
error but the media's just covering for
him Greg you know I was gonna say what
I've said before but it kind of drives
me crazy that he had Chris Rock and
Rosie Perez they're kind of like a
celebrity bells and whistles but the
pandemic the pandemic reveals I think
the true weaknesses and strengths of our
country we found out about American
unity innovation and Industry
but our weaknesses were bureaucracy the
media politics and elder care so I think
we need you know to look at revamping
nursing homes to get better pay for the
people that are there to entice better
personnel tax credits for family with
elderly limit the number of dwelling or
dwell people who live there so you don't
have a World War two vet you know
sitting in his own you know stuff for
three hours because nobody's there the
fact is this is like the this is the
finish line of life and if you are lucky
you're gonna make it to that age only to
be kicked off the planet in the most
degrading way possible your reward for
making it it's long for defending a
country raising a family doing great
things in this world is your reward is
abuse and neglect and that's the big
story is how we warehouse the elderly
like their burdens with a pulse when in
fact they should be treasured invaluable
and valued because they gave so much and
we're giving them so little we should
definitely treat our elders with more
more respect than that and the governor
definitely said take an L on this